at tokyo's haneda airport a bella
russian sprinter
is being protected by police against the
threat
she claims that's from her home nation
christina simanowskaya says she was
being forcibly repatriated
for publicly criticizing her coaches and
so posted a video online
calling for help i'm asking the
international olympic committee for help
i'm being put under pressure to leave
the country i'm asking the ioc to get
involved in this
the ioc says it's spoken with the 24
year old who's being guarded by police
and received assurances from airport
staff that she is safe
a japanese refugee lawyer was seen
speaking to officers
offering the athlete council after
running in the hundred meter heats on
friday
she was due to compete in the 200 meters
on monday but the athlete was withdrawn
from the games completely
after complaining online about how she
had been entered into another event
the 400 meter relay at short notice
what followed campaigners say was yet
another example
of the belarussian surveillance state
and how its citizens
aren't even safe on the other side of
the world
this whole situation began when
pro-government and propaganda channels
started a negative campaign against her
it was quite serious and a clear signal
that her life would be in danger in
belarus
dissent is rapidly stamped out in the
eastern european country
where authoritarian leader alexander
lukashenko has held power for nearly 30
years
mass protests against a disputed
election last summer
were followed by brutal crackdown that
saw athletes who took part
defunded demoted and detained
the belarusian olympic committee says
tsimonowskai was taken off the team
because of her emotional and
psychological condition
she says it's because she spoke out and
is now
refusing to return home iva bennett sky
news